they turned up in the hope rather than
the belief that my dough would make it
back to Venezuela and on to this rally
incorrect
they weren't disappointed this
charismatic leader of the Opposition to
Nicolas maduro's rule here was greeted
as a returning hero he literally has to
push through the crowds thousands
screaming their appreciation he's toured
South American capitals since crossing
to Colombia to oversee the unsuccessful
delivery of aid to the country despite
the United States warning of a
significant response he could easily be
arrested he told the crowd that he is
back for good and urge them to stay on
the streets and ignore threats of
violence after all the threats and after
all the head despread there's only one
thing one thing that can defeat hate and
that is love love of our people love to
help and to serve it is what we're doing
but despite the rallies the adoring fans
and the international recognition
nothing has really changed here Maduro
and the security forces are very much in
control the opposition needs one try
though because these thousands of people
on the street
in the show up or they're simply going
to lose momentum
opposition supporters say they will
continue to press for change some want a
military intervention or at least more
international support despite the
apparent empress here they remain
determined we need to get our democracy
back and we are going to keep on the
streets fighting for our democracy okay
that's the common feeling anyhow we need
we need support from other countries
from the international community because
we cannot fight this alone and are
people getting tired of having to wait
though this is you know nearly two
months now right now I mean good ones
but if you think about it it's been 20
years so you can wait a couple more
months and I will I will do it I mean I
think it's necessary and I think we can
finally get the feeling that the crowds
really can't get enough of this man and
he has learned to appeal to their belief
that changes imminent more protests are
being planned more mass demonstrations
no doubt Nicolas Maduro and his
supporters have got the message but it
doesn't mean they or the military have
any intention of listening
James of Sky News correct